Captain Carter Deadpool 3 The Adventures
of Wong let's review every Marvel
spin-off currently in development as
well as every rumored project still on
the horizon there are currently 26
confirmed MCU projects in development
and 21 more rumored but not yet
confirmed that's almost 50 titles coming
in the next several years and today
we're going to be breaking down
everything we know about each of these
spin-offs stick around to the end to
find out how one spin-off film was
canceled costing Marvel and Disney
Millions since there's almost 50 titles
in this list we're going to go through
them pretty fast let's start with a
confirmed MCU projects first up we have
Ant-Man and the WASP quantumania with a
release date set for February 17 2023.
in this film Ant-Man and the WASP find
themselves exploring the quantum realm
interacting with strange new creatures
and embarking on an adventure that
pushes them beyond the limits of what
they thought was possible up next is
secret Invasion the television series
starring Samuel L Jackson set to hit
Disney plus sometime in early 2023 this
series will follow the story of a
faction of shape shifting aliens called
Scrolls who have infiltrated all aspects
of life on Earth next up is the second
season of the Disney plus animated
series what if set to release in early
2023 this season will likely follow
characters we came to know in the first
season as well as start new stories that
all come together in the season finale
once again next we have Guardians of the
Galaxy vol 3 with the release date set
for May 5th 2023. this story will follow
the Guardians after the events of
Avengers end game and the Guardians of
the Galaxy holiday special next on the
list is Echo a Disney plus series set to
release in mid-2023 this series will
follow Maya Lopez after the events of
Hawkeye as she returns to her hometown
in Oklahoma where she must come to terms
with her past up next we have Loki
season 2 with a release date set in
mid-2023 this series will follow Loki
and morbius after the events of Loki
season 1 finale which saw the death of
he who remains and started an all-out
multiversal War next we have the Marvels
with a release date set for July 28th
2023 this film will feature the
characters Carol Danvers or Captain
Marvel Kamala Khan or Ms Marvel and
Monica Rambo our next spin-off is
ironheart a Disney Plus show set to
release in late 2023 this series will
follow Riri Williams the MIT student and
genius inventor from Chicago who created
a suit of armor that Rivals even the
ones built by Tony Stark up next is
Agatha coven of chaos another Disney
plus series coming in late 2023 the
series will follow Agatha Harkness after
the events of One Division and will once
again star Catherine Han as Agatha next
on our list is X-Men 97 continuing the
story from X-Men the Animated Series in
1992. this show is set to release
sometime in late 2023
next up we have Spider-Man freshman year
another animated series which will
follow Peter Parker's early days as
Spider-Man soon after gaining his powers
this series is set to release an early
2024. another animated series is next on
the list Marvel Zombies set to release
in early 2024. this show will reimagine
the Marvel universe as a new generation
of Heroes battle against an
ever-spreading zombie Scourge up next is
Daredevil Born Again a Disney plus
series set to release in mid-2024 this
show will continue Matt Murdoch's story
as Daredevil and it will star Charlie
Cox as our favorite acrobatic attorney
next we have armor Wars a project
starring Don Cheadle as Roadie which was
originally meant to be a series but now
will be a feature film set to release in
mid-2024. this movie will answer the
question of what would happen if Tony
Stark's Tech fell into the wrong hands
next up is Captain America New World
Order set to release on May 3rd 2024.
this film will follow Sam Wilson as the
newly appointed Captain America after
the events of Falcon and the Winter
Soldier a our next spin-off is
thunderbolts which will follow Valentina
Allegra de fontaine's team of
anti-heroes the Thunderbolts starring
Florence Pugh as Elena bolova Sebastian
Stan as the Winter Soldier Wyatt Russell
as a U.S agent Olga kurylinko as
Taskmaster David Harbor as Red Guardian
Hannah John come on as ghost and
Harrison Ford as Thaddeus Ross this film
has a release date set for July 26 2024.
up next is blade a film featuring the
day walking vampire blade played by
mahershala Ali this movie has a release
date set for September 6 2024. next we
have Deadpool 3 following the adventures
of Ryan Reynolds Deadpool and Hugh
Jackman's Wolverine this film currently
has a release date confirmed for
November 8 2024. next on the list is
Fantastic Four this film will bring one
of the most iconic Marvel teams to the
big screen once again and it has a
release date set for February 14 2025.
up next we have Avengers the King
Dynasty and Avengers Secret Wars the
back-to-back films to wrap up phase six
of the MCU these movies have release
dates set for May 2nd 2025 and May 1st
2026. there are five more confirmed
projects with unknown release dates the
Untitled wakanda series a series
following Wonder Man the Nova special
presentation Xiang Chi 2 and the Silver
Surfer special presentation now that we
know every confirmed Marvel spin-off
let's get into the rumored ones remember
to stick around to the end for Marvel's
canceled film which cost them millions
also hit the Subscribe button for more
videos like this our first rumored
series is Vision Quest a Disney plus
series starring Paul bettany's Vision as
he tries to regain his memory one of my
favorite rumored series though is the
adventures of Wong another Disney plus
series which would follow Wong Master of
the mystical Arts current sorcerer
Supreme and the biggest fan of The
Sopranos it's also rumored that we'll
see a fourth feature-length Spider-Man
film as well as an animated series
titled Spider-Man sophomore year
following the confirmed freshman year
series there are also rumors of feature
films is being developed for the
characters Madame Webb Adam Warlock
Howard the Duck Ghost Rider the Black
Knight and spider Gwen each of these
characters have more than enough
backstory to Warrant their own feature
films so I wouldn't be surprised if
these ones actually make it to the big
screen it's also been rumored that a
fifth Thor film is in the works
following the story from Thor love and
thunder there are also rumors of several
live-action television shows in the
works following what if's Captain Carter
the Agents of Atlas the Young Avengers
and World War Hulk again each of these
characters and story lines have plenty
of comic content to work with and lots
of setup already seen in MCU projects so
I'm confident that at least a few of
these projects will make it to fruition
up next are a few X-Men related projects
a series titled the mutants a feature
film for the character Rogue and one
final Wolverine movie there's also
rumors of a Hercules project in
development following the events of Thor
love and thunder as well as a third
Venom film following the events of
Spider-Man no way home our last rumored
project is Captain in America the last
mission which would follow Steve Rogers
as he goes back in time to return the
Infinity Stones to their respective
timelines before finding his one true
love Peggy Carter now for the Marvel
movie that was canceled costing Marvel
Millions several different screenwriters
and directors have been working for
almost a decade on a feature film for
the Marvel character Gambit since there
were several changes in directors and
producers it took almost 10 years and
lots of money to finally get something
in motion star Channing Tatum even
signed on to co-produce the film and
play the main character Gambit a mutant
skilled and card throwing and capable of
manipulating kinetic energy the film was
said to have an R rating and a similar
tone to that of Deadpool after several
delays in the release date it was
eventually set to hit theaters on March
13 2020 with filming to begin in early
2019. in January of 2019 though Disney
purchased Fox who owned the rights to
the X-Men and Gambit and they put all
new projects on hold in May of 2019 it
was announced that the film was
officially canceled and removed from the
release schedule although we aren't
quite sure of the exact total this
nightmare of a project costs Fox and
Disney millions and it will likely never
see the light of day but I'd like to
know what you think which rumored
project would you like to get confirmed
by Marvel drop your thoughts in the
comment section below also check out the
video on your screen for some more of my
content don't forget to like And
subscribe and thanks for watching Rocket
Riley